[Música]
vivemos na era mais rápido e tecnológica
da história
o acesso a toda informação quisermos
alcançar na ponta dos nossos dedos
tudo muda numa rapidez absurda música
dança pesquisa ciências conceitos
medicina cultura lembra quando não era
netflix ela dvd e nem o dvd
lembro quando era fita cassete e alguns
anos atrás que o telefone só existia
dentro de casa
computador smartphone são tantas
inovações disruptivas que mudam mais e
mais a cada dia ea escola
talvez se tivesse tido mais mudanças
sofrido mais evoluções com o tempo foi o
que mais ficou pra trás
a escola parece quase parada no tempo
que a gente considera a situação atual
do nosso mundo
no brasil o sistema permanece quase o
mesmo há praticamente 500 anos e nada
disso evolui quando uma criança nasce já
se sabe com o provável caminho que ela
vai seguir ela vai entrar na escola vai
ser alfabetizada tirar boas notas para
poder passar de ano entrar no ensino
médio e seguir as regras e ter uma vida
social fazer atividades extra
curriculares para poder dormir bem e em
se formar entrar na faculdade fazer um
bom estágio para conseguir formar mais
uma vez entrar no mundo do trabalho se
aposentar aos 60 anos
será que é assim que a gente vai ter
pessoas que entendam sobre si mesmo e
sejam capazes de mudar o mundo o brasil
é o país com maior taxa de ansiedade no
mundo eo quinto em casos de depressão
de acordo com a organização mundial da
saúde esse número é crescente entre
jovens é claro que esse sistema não
acolhe a todos
o certo nem sempre acerta para todo
mundo
a minha trajetória com scott foi sempre
bem tranquila apesar de ter estudado em
muitos lugares foram seis escolas em 12
anos de estudos
e eu sempre fui uma boa aluna tirava
boas notas e vai comportar
nada eu nunca fui na soja da diretoria
nem fiquei de recuperação
os professores gostava de mim eu gostava
dele e por mais que eu ficasse nervosa
para fazer prova não era nada fora do
comum e eu tenho uma amiga chamada
sabrina a sabrina dar muito problema na
escola ela é questionadora
ela sempre ia pra sala da diretora
ficava sempre recuperação tirava notas
horríveis e em muitos sentidos e nós
sabíamos opostas mas tem uma coisa que
chama muito a atenção
nós duas nos encaixamos do sistema
tradicional de educação brasileiro
a gente não entendia porque a gente
tinha que aprender uma fórmula
matemática ou citar elementos da tabela
periódica esse nosso interesse não tinha
nada a ver com aquilo a gente não
entendia porque ciência não tinha o
mesmo peso que música dança teatro
se você muda as pessoas com sorte que
consegue utilizar grande parte de
conhecimentos adquiridos na escola tá
tudo bem não tem nada de errado com você
mas eu estou aqui para dizer que também
não tem nada de errado com a gente que
não se encaixa
eu tô aqui pra falar sobre o tabu que
todo mundo esconde embaixo do tapete
porque existe sim vida fora da escola
a vida acontece apesar da escola mas a
idéia é o sistema de que tudo que a
gente faz tem que seguir aquele caminho
padrão para a gente ser alguém na vida
isso deve muito dentro da gente
a desvalorização é um movimento de parar
entender o que realmente faz parte de
mim que o que faz parte desse sistema
que eu acabei devolvendo a decisão todos
os dias de ser libertados paradigmas que
são impostos por alguém que a gente nem
sabe quem é a desvalorização não o
simples fato de sair da escola é um modo
de encarar a vida é entender que o mundo
a nossa escola a gente aprende com os
aprendizados que a gente vai encontrando
pela vida das felicidades os problemas e
não aqueles que são impostos pra gente
no ambiente artificial
eu tive muito apoio inicialmente
principalmente da minha mãe que estudou
bastante sobre a descolonização quando
cometeu comecei a ter algumas questões
na escola
e ela chegou com essa ideia pra mim e eu
comecei a ficar muito aflita
eu falei não mas com assim que você na
minha vida o que vou fazer como é que
vou ter uma profissão sem independente
financeiramente como é que eu vou fazer
amigos mas eu parei e eu estudei as
minhas possibilidade e eu descobri foi
que eu podia fazer uma prova e ganhar um
certificado de ensino médio desde 2008 e
nem servirá para aqueles com mais de 18
anos que queriam conseguir o diploma ea
em 2007 2017
o ano que eu ia completar 18 anos mudou
mas não mudou muito
eu ainda podia fazer uma única prova e
ganhar modificada de ensino médio mas
agora pelo enseja o exame nacional de
certificação de competências de jovens e
adultos
e aí eu me inscrevi no site esperei duas
informações de quando e onde eu ia fazer
a prova
ela é gratuita e é dada em todo o brasil
e no exterior
você pode fazer a 15 anos e se formar no
ensino fundamental ou você pode fazer
algo com 18 anos e mesmo sem ter feito o
ensino fundamental você consegue o
diploma para os dois ciclos
e aí eu estudei tudo no meu tempo
entendendo que fazia mais sentido pra
mim que eu tinha mais ou menos
dificuldade
e aí o dia da prova cheguei lá sem ter a
minha cadeirinha e aí marquei durante
quatro horas questões de múltipla
escolha e no intervalo é encontrar
alguns amigos meus que para minha
surpresa também tinham saído da escola
porque eles entenderam que aquilo também
não fazia sentido para eles e aí eu não
sei
voltei pra e cinco horas de prova em que
eu marquei mais questões múltipla
escolha e fiz a minha redação e depois
disso foi só esperar o resultado
três meses depois eu soube que tinha
passado
e naquele momento foi um misto de
emoções
claro que eu fiquei muito feliz e fiquei
contente por ter conseguido terminar
esse processo da minha vida mas eu
fiquei muito
muito estranho porque as pessoas passam
três anos na escola pra ter o exato
mesmo resultado que eu tive que é um
papel escrito você completou o ensino
médio mas esse não foi meu maior desafio
nem mesmo o aprendizado esse não foi o
meu processo de descolonização pra mim
tudo só começou depois de alguns meses
sem fazer absolutamente nada a não ser
ver televisão e sair com meus amigos e
era isso que eu fazia
até eu entender que não dava mais para
ser assim e eu sozinha percebi que eu
tive me movimentar pra seguir a minha
vida então eu fui atrás daquilo que me
fazer feliz e eu fiz muitos cursos
eu fiz um galho jovem eu fiz curso de
leitura de aura cursos de cura prânica
reiki meditação e se todos que me
ajudaram muito no meu processo de
autoconhecimento e pra mim foram
totalmente essenciais no processo de
desvalorização porque entende que se não
me conhecesse
eu não ia conseguir tomar e manter essa
decisão e aí eu estudei também muito
sobre como comunicar como entendeu meus
sentimentos entender o que eu gosto que
definitivamente não gosto entender como
ouvir os outros e entender também no
espaço beta minha disse escola de ensino
médio
lá a gente tomava todas as decisões em
roda jovens e adultos pensando que seria
melhor pra gente tanto individualmente
quanto em grupo
além disso eu fiz várias aulas que
encantam demais até hoje como o
sapateado canto dança teatro e isso pra
mim móvel demais em algum momento eu
também queria fazer algo pelas pessoas
que entende que isso é muito especial
para mim e eu comecei a dar aula de
inglês uma ong e estar num lugar onde
não era rotulada por não ter diploma de
ensino médio foi muito importante pra
mim eu estava ali pra ensinar inglês e
eu precisava saber para ensinar inglês e
apaixonante pra mim tá no ambiente onde
eu possa inserir processos mais livre
dentro de uma sala de aula enquanto
também vejo brilho nos olhos dos meus
alunos que notam o próprio potencial que
ele já tem hoje em dia eu também dou
aula dentro de uma escola para crianças
e eu trabalho na esef como voluntária
enviando alunos e ralos enviando jovens
para desenvolverem sua liderança e
através de intercâmbios e pra mim tudo
que eu faço é pela minha vontade e pelo
meu entendimento do que eu gosto do que
eu não gosto do que eu sou e do que eu
quero ser o seu processo de
desvalorização pode e deve ser bem
diferente do meu
ele deve ter apenas a ver com o que você
quer pelo seu entendimento de quem você
quer ser você tem ativamente do atrás
daquilo que te faz feliz
obrigada
[Aplausos]